EVE ANDERSON: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Eve Anderson.
I lead the accessibility
engineering group at Google.
And I'm here with
some of my colleagues.
We have software
engineers Phil Weaver,
Hugh Oh, and Casey Burkhardt.
We're also joined by a very
special guest, Mark Riccobono,
the President of the National
Federation of the Blind.
Today, we're going to talk with
you about improving your apps
accessibility to
make it work better
for people with disabilities.
This is a very important topic,
and I'm glad you're here.
The World Health
Organization estimates
that 15% of the
world's population
has some form of disability.
That's over one billion people.
To put that into context, that's
three times the population
of the United States
and more than all
of Europe put together.
By making your app accessible
to people with disabilities,
you have the ability
to empower people,
to help give people
independence,
to help give them
access to knowledge.
Furthermore, a well-designed
accessible application
can be more usable for
all users of your app.
So by working on
accessibility, it
will pay dividends over time.
Now I'd like to introduce
you to Phil Weaver
and Hugh Oh will
be doing the demo.
We're going to show you
some accessibility features
of the Android platform
and talk about what
you can do to help make
sure that your app works
with these features.
Take it away.
PHIL WEAVER: So my
name is Phil Weaver.
I'm a software engineer in the
accessibility team at Google.
And as Eve mentioned,
accessibility's aim
is really to help serve the
billion people worldwide
who are affected by
some form of disability.
Now, a billion is
really a lot of people
to try to wrap your head around.
It's really possible to do.
There's not one thing we can
do to help all billion people.
So it's impossible to
make generalizations.
But I've built some really
valuable relationships
with a number of people with
disabilities as friends,
as neighbors, as co-workers.
And I really value
these relationships,
both professionally as someone
who works on accessibility,
but more importantly
really personally as far
as what they bring to my life.
And I think these
relationships are
a reminder of both what we would
lose if we weren't including
people with disabilities
as well as we are now
and really how much
potential there
is if we can bring
more people into this
fold and include
more and more people.
And that's really what we're
trying to do with accessibility
is include people and
workplaces and schools
in the design of
our technologies.
And the way I think
about accessibility
is it's challenging our
assumptions about our users
and about the things we
design and then finding
a better way to design things.
And it ends up being a
better outcome for everyone.
So the relationship
with somebody
with a disability that I
value the most is with my son.
So he was born
with a disability,
and he's now six years old.
And watching him grow
has really forced
me to look at a
lot of assumptions
that I've held my own beliefs.
And it's also made me a
really strong advocate
for inclusive education.
As a parent, it's obvious why
I'd be interested in that.
I want him to grow up and get
used to living in the world
that he's going to
grow into and hopefully
be a big productive part of.
But the interesting
thing about it
is that research really shows
that including everybody
in the same classroom
in education
is actually good for everybody--
it's good for his classmates
too.
It exposes classmates to
a wider group of people.
It forces his teachers
to think more critically
about the assumptions they're
making about their students.
And the educational
outcomes actually
end up being better
for everybody.
And interestingly, the same
story happens with software.
So I suspect a lot of us
here use auto complete.
I probably couldn't
live without it.
And not everybody realize
that it was actually
invented to help people
with disabilities
to communicate more effectively.
Somebody who can't speak
or has trouble typing,
the ability to auto complete is
actually a tremendous benefit.
And 20 odd years ago, that
was actually the application.
People were writing
academic papers
about how to do auto
complete really targeted
at that user base.
And today, we don't
really think of it
as an accessibility
accommodation.
It's something that
we just use every day
without thinking about it.
I think that's an
interesting example
that when we challenge
the assumptions we make
about our users, we can
come up with solutions that
have tremendous
benefits not just
for the people we start
off thinking about
but to help everybody.
We get these new thinking
we get new designs new ideas
and new categories of products.
But we want to talk
about your app.
So we figured we'd
start with an app.
And the app we're going to
use is one that Eve wrote.
This is to help
everybody memorize
digits of pi-- so a noble goal.
So what we're going to do is
look at how this app works,
talk about the assumptions
that it's default design makes,
and see how the accessibility
features in Android
can relax those assumptions.
And look at some best
practices that apps
can follow to make
that process work well
and introduce some testing
tools for the nuts and bolts
of these best practices.
So she calls it elephant
pi because elephants
have good memories.
And this is the test
yourself activity.
So it lets you type
in digits of pi
and it tells you when
you got something wrong.
So Hugh is going to start this
app and show you how it works
and hopefully impress everybody
with his knowledge of pi.
So we can switch
to the wolf please.
HUGH OH: Hi, I'm Hugh.
I'm a software engineer
on the accessibility team,
and I'm just going to show you
what the default behavior will
be with elephant pi.
So I've got a keypad
here at the bottom.
And so as I type them
out-- so 3.14159--
it also reflects that
in a text box above.
And if I go ahead
and make a mistake,
it will go ahead and tell me
what the digit should have been
and highlights the
wrong digit in red.
So this is the default case.
It's simple but
effective in learning pi.
EVE ANDERSON: All right, you
can go back to the slides.
So if any of you just got funded
and you're developing an app
to help people
memorize digits of pi,
then I guess you're
going to spend
the rest of this day just trying
to pivot to something new.
But fortunately,
apparently your investors
have an irrational exuberance.
But what we've seen is
the default experience.
And it's really making
a lot of assumptions.
And if you're used to
the default experience,
you may not really be
thinking about them.
But we're assuming users
can see this great.
We're assuming that
users can touch
the screen with a reasonable
amount of precision--
that they can read, that
they can understand what
the directions are
saying, understand what
they're supposed to be doing.
And perhaps most
tenuous of all, we're
assuming that people
actually want to hear
others memorize digits of pi.
And not all these assumptions
are true for all the users--
certainly, they're not true
for everybody in this room.
And accessibility isn't going to
address all these assumptions.
This one you probably
have to challenge
with user testing or something.
Hopefully, user testing
that would include users
with disabilities.
But with accessibility,
we really
can address some
assumptions that
become real barriers for
people to access in technology.
We'll take a look
at a few of them.
We have the services called
accessibility services
in Android.
And the first one I want to
show you is called TalkBack.
And this ships with Android.
And it's a screen reader.
And what a screen reader
does is remove the assumption
that users can see the screen.
But it replaces it with the
assumption that users can hear.
And so it'll read
what's on the screen,
and guide with this spoken
feedback, guide users
to find the actions they want
to take to navigate the device.
So Hugh is now going to show
you the pi app using TalkBack.
Switch back to the wolf please.
HUGH OH: OK, so we have
the same exact application.
But let's go ahead
and turn on TalkBack.
I'll go ahead and
turn it back on.
TALKBACK: Test yourself.
HUGH OH: OK, so I will go
ahead and use a feature
called ExploreByTouch where
it reads out everything
that I'm touching as I explore
the screen with my finger.
So let's go ahead and
go over to the three
and see what we can find.
TALKBACK: One button.
Two button.
Three button.
HUGH OH: And then
once I have the button
that I want to select, I
just go ahead and double tap.
And it appears as if I tapped
it from the earlier case.
So let's do a couple more.
TALKBACK: Point button.
One button.
HUGH OH: And let's go ahead
and make a mistake right now
and see what happens.
TALKBACK: Wrong, should be four.
HUGH OH: And it notifies me
audibly on top of visually
to tell me, hey, you've
got a digit wrong.
And this is how TalkBack
interacts with elephant pi.
PHIL WEAVER: OK, let's
go back to the slides.
So that's TalkBack.
There's another service
that can work with TalkBack
called BrailleBack.
And so that replaces
the assumption
that users can hear with one
that they can read Braille.
And it sends all
the spoken feedback
to a refreshable
Braille display.
And we're not going to
demo that right here.
It's sort of a tactile demo.
If you're interested to see
how a Braille display works,
we're over in the
google.org area.
And you're welcome
to stop by later
and talk about
anything you like.
So all these things expand
the Android user base.
And another thing
we can do is try
to relax the assumptions that
users can touch the screen
with any degree of precision.
And so we have switch
access that does this.
And it ships with Android
starting and Lollipop.
And it replaces this assumption
that users can touch the screen
as long as they have a switch.
These switches
could be big buttons
like Hugh is going to
demonstrate in a moment
or something as high tech
as determining when somebody
can contract a single muscle.
So this is really trying to make
as few assumptions about users
as possible in their ability
to control the device.
So Hugh is now going
to drive the pi
app using a single button.
And he's going to use a feature
called auto scanning, which
is going to highlight each item
one at a time on the screen--
everything that's
clickable-- and then
when it gets to the thing
that he wants to click on,
he hits the button again.
So let's switch back
to the wolf please.
HUGH OH: OK, so we're
back to our original app.
And as you can see here, I've
got a brand new button here--
also known as a switch.
And I've only got one.
So it both starts
the auto-scanning,
which starts from the top left
and goes to the bottom right
and goes linearly.
And the same button will
also select an element.
So let's go ahead and
see what that looks like.
So I started the scanning.
It starts on the top left
and goes to every actual one.
And then I hit it again and
it's as if I had touched it.
So we can go ahead and
make a mistake here,
and it still notifies
you visually that, hey,
something wrong happened.
But it still behaves
exactly the same way.
So this is how switch access
interacts with elephant pi.
PHIL WEAVER: So go back
to the slides please.
So there we have three
services-- TalkBack,
BrailleBack and switch access--
that remove and replace
different assumptions
that we make about users
and how they're going to
interact with an Android
device.
Now, the nice
thing about Android
is it's a very open platform.
So any developer can write a new
service with a completely new
interaction model to try to
address whatever assumptions
he or she wants to break down,
serve any group of users.
In theory, every user could
actually have his or her very
own experience.
This is sort of a way of
doing mass customization.
But how does this work?
So very high level,
this magic happens
inside the Android framework.
So the Android
framework knows what's
being put on the screen,
what's clickable,
where it is, what its
bounds on the screen are,
what has text, so
on and so forth.
And it builds an event stream of
everything going on the screen.
And accessibility services
can subscribe to the stream
and can pay attention to
different parts of it.
So the switch access
service is going
to really care about when
clickable things change
on the screen.
TalkBack and BrailleBack need
to understand when something
happens called live
region that will need
to be announced to the user.
And the nice thing about this
is the app really is unaware
that this is going on.
It's not aware of
this back channel,
but it can do quite
a bit to support it.
So one of things it can do
is add content descriptions.
I said Android knows
what's on the screen,
but what it doesn't
know is what it means.
So if I use text buttons or Eve
would use text buttons instead
of image buttons to
enter digits of pi,
Android would have known
exactly what these things were
because they're labeled.
But instead, we needed to have
these pretty purple circles.
And these become images.
And when we use images to
convey information to users,
we're making the
implicit assumption
that they can see the images.
So we need some way to
make that this mean can get
conveyed in other ways as well.
And the main way we do that is
through content descriptions.
These extra text that you
can add to any view that gets
passed along to any active
accessibility services.
So we've content descriptions
to all these buttons-- one, two,
three, four, and so on.
And notice they
say what they do.
And TalkBack ads on the fact
that their role in this thing
is a button.
So the single most common
accessibility related bug
is for someone just to
forget to put a content
description on an image.
And then TalkBack has to
automatically label it.
And it essentially becomes
difficult for users
who can't see the
screen to understand
what a button is going to do.
So if everybody
does nothing else,
if you add content
descriptions to all images that
convey meaning, that
will really help
us relax that assumption that
all users can see the screen.
The other thing is not
all text on the screen
is equally important.
Some of it can just be left
on the screen for users
to discover on their own-- like
the directions of what to do.
But some text, like when
Hugh makes a mistake
on entering digits of pi, he
wants to know that right away.
You don't want to
type one thing in
and then have to
scroll around to see
if you got something
wrong or right
and then go and
enter another digit.
And so we made
this a live region.
And a live region means that
whenever that view updates,
it's going to generate an extra
event in this event stream
that accessibility services
can pay attention to.
And we label it Polite, not just
because we like to be polite,
but that means it shouldn't
really interrupt anything else.
So this is important
information,
but it's not like we have
to stop all other audio
from playing before we
can tell people that they
got a digit wrong of pi.
So that's a little bit
about what we did to the app
to make it work
well with TalkBack.
Now let's break it.
So we'll go through and take
this nice accessible app
that you've wrote and we'll
delete all the content
descriptions except
one, where we'll just
add some redundant text.
We'll add the fact
that it's a button.
And we'll get rid
of the live region
too just for good measure.
And now Hugh can show you
this broken experience.
So let's switch to the wolf.
HUGH OH: OK, so it
looks exactly the same.
But let's hear what a broken
experience sounds like.
So let's go ahead and
enable TalkBack again.
TALKBACK: Test yourself.
HUGH OH: So we unable
everything and then
we had a redundant
button at the seven.
So let's make our way
to the seven button.
I'll be passing over the
one and the four button.
Let's hear what
those sound like.
TALKBACK: Buton 96, unlabeled.
Button 79, unlabeled.
Seven button button.
HUGH OH: So you can hear
it tried its best to give
a name to unlabeled
buttons, but like we said,
we don't understand the meaning.
And then seven button button
had a redundant button in there.
So let's also hear what happens
if I get something wrong,
and let's just do
that right away.
So I'll double tap.
And so it shows us visually
that we've got something wrong,
but we're missing
the audio queue here.
And this is how TalkBack
interacts with an inaccessible
version of the app.
PHIL WEAVER: Let's switch
back to the slides.
So those are a couple
of issues that affected
the experience with talkback.
But switch access makes
very different assumptions
about our users, and thus is
affected by different types
of accessibility related bugs.
So I'll show you one example.
So in order to structure
the Android UI,
I've added a bunch
of linear layouts.
And actually I've
got at least one
in there that isn't
strictly required.
Sometimes I end up adding a
couple extra layouts in there
just to try to get
things to look right.
Once I get to that point,
I figure, OK, good enough.
And generally, it
is good enough.
But if we say that
all of these things
are clickable-- so we make
extraneous views on the screen
clickable-- now we've
told the Android framework
that these do something.
And so it's going to
tell switch access.
Switch access wants
to make sure that it's
giving all the options
it can to the users.
And so it's going to
surface these extra
I call them decoy
clickable views.
It's going to surface
those to our users.
And that creates a confusing
and slow experience that really
isn't good enough anymore.
So we'll look at the
pi app one last time
using the switch access
with this broken activity.
So we'll go back to the wolf.
HUGH OH: OK, so we have
the same inaccessible app,
but let's see how the breakages
happen with switch access.
So I've got my single red button
here, the same one from before.
But let's start
the auto scanning.
And as you can see, there's
these extra outlines
that are being
presented to the user.
And there's no real
rhyme or reason
why they're grouping the
entire thing or given rows,
but as far as the
user is concerned,
it seems like these are
supposed to be actionable.
So I'm going to go ahead and let
this finish its auto scanning.
And I'm going to try to select
one of these brand new dummy
containers.
So let's go ahead
and see what happens.
So nothing happened.
It's confusing to the
user as to what happened,
and on top of that,
you have to scan
through these every
single time, which
can make for a really
grueling experience
when you have to scan
through all these.
These are just obstacles in the
way that are slowing you down.
And this is how switch
access interacts
with the same inaccessible
version of the app.
PHIL WEAVER: OK, let's
go back to the slides.
So to see these kinds
of bugs, we really
have to start an
accessibility service.
We've implemented the same
activity twice in order
to demonstrate these bugs.
But you really can't
tell them apart
if you're just using the
default experience of touching
the screen, seeing the screen.
But obviously they
have a major effect
on accessibility services.
And I've shown you the
code as we went along.
Here's the DIF between
the two activities.
These are very
small scale changes.
And a big aspect of
improving apps accessibility
is essentially to make
sure this kind of code
gets into the app source.
This is fairly typical for
the scale of changes needed
to make an activity accessible.
But they're also
easy to overlook.
Developers are working very
hard to make sure their default
experience is ready to ship, and
it takes a lot about discipline
to make sure this kind of
markup still gets into the app
and gets in there consistently.
And the problem is
very similar to making
sure the stuff we're
working on today
doesn't break the stuff
that we worked on last week.
So testing is the way we can
make sure that accessibility
gets done right.
So let's talk about testing.
And Casey is going to--
thanks a lot for your help,
Hugh-- Casey is going
to show us a cool thing
we've been working on.
CASEY BURKHARDT:
Let's have Phil's mic.
PHIL WEAVER: So we've been
doing a demonstration all along
about how to test
for accessibility.
We started TalkBack, we
started switch access,
we saw how things worked.
Ideally, we'd start
up BrailleBack,
and ideally we'd find
every accessibility service
that anyone in the developer
community has built
and try that out as well.
This is going to take some time.
It's going to be hard to scale.
We're not going to be able to do
this, certainly, every time we
make a change to our app.
And we're going to have
to train any testers who
are going to do this kind of
testing on every service that's
out there.
But what if there
was an app that could
automate some of this testing?
Somewhat interested,
very interested,
extremely interested?
So Casey is going to show
us a project that we've
been working on in
Google Research that
does a lot of this automation.
CASEY BURKHARDT: Thanks, Phil.
PHIL WEAVER: Let's
switch to the wolf.
CASEY BURKHARDT: My
name is Casey Burkhardt.
I'm a software
engineer on Google's
accessibility engineering
team and research.
And we just wanted to give
you an early look at something
we've been working on
to help make identifying
accessibility issues within
your Android applications
fast and easy.
Here we have the same
broken activity--
the same test
yourself activity--
that we've
intentionally introduced
some accessibility issues.
So basically,
you've seen earlier
how these issues impact the
experience with TalkBack
and switch access.
The only thing different
with this device
is we've enabled Accessibility
Checker for Android.
And what that's done is it
has placed a floating action
button near the top
right of the display.
And if we click
this action button,
it's going to actually trigger
an accessibility evaluation
of the foreground activity
of the current application.
And it's going to use the
same exact accessibility
APIs that TalkBack or
BrailleBack or switch access
might use to provide more
information to the user
about your application.
Except, it's
looking specifically
for accessibility defects.
So if we run this
evaluation, we will basically
traverse our
application's hierarchy
and we'll see what
issues we identify.
So it will bring
up a results UI.
It looks like we found that
duplicate clickable view
from earlier that we saw causing
some inefficiencies with switch
access.
We also see a number of missing
speakable descriptions here
related to missing
content descriptions
on our digit buttons.
We want to go back
and make sure we're
providing reasonable
content descriptions there.
And finally, we have a
redundantly labeled view.
It looks like our seven
button incorrectly
has the word button appended
to the end of its content
description.
We saw the impact of
that little earlier.
So now that we've identified
all of these issues
in a simple results activity,
we just need to fix them.
PHIL WEAVER: All right, we
can go back to the slides.
Thanks for that feedback, Casey.
Fortunately, I do have
a patch ready for you
if you can take a look at it.
CASEY BURKHARDT:
Yeah, we've added back
some content descriptions.
We've removed that
clickable view.
Looks good to me.
PHIL WEAVER: Stay with
the slides, please.
So I've got Casey to say
it looks good to him.
That's something
I always cherish.
And this is really the
workflow that we want to see.
We want to see detailed,
actionable feedback getting
back to developers
quickly so that they
can make fairly small scale
changes to make sure they
build quality products.
So we're working hard
to get this tool out to.
It is still manual
testing, though.
So it's something
that if you wanted
to do it every time
you make a change,
it becomes tricky to do
any sort of manual test
if you've got some large
scale development effort.
What we really want to
do is catch these bugs as
early as possible,
and to do that,
we want to get into the
code development loop.
So we've taken the
core of this checker
and released it as an
open source library
for accessibility testing.
And we've integrated this
into two popular testing
frameworks-- Espresso
and Robolectric.
I'll show you how it
works in both frameworks.
So Espresso I'll
talk about first.
It's a test framework for
Android user interfaces.
And accessibility checking
is available as of yesterday
in version 2.2 in the
Espresso contrib area.
So just to show you very
briefly how Espresso works.
If you've ever done
any Android UI testing,
you find there's a
bit of subtlety to it.
You have to make sure
you understand what
thread things are running in.
There ends up being a lot of
boilerplate synchronization
code.
So if you want to do a
simple test that does, say,
three things-- type some text
into a field, clicks a button,
makes sure text updates
properly in another field--
that can often end up being
a significant amount of code.
Espresso does a really
nice job of wrapping
a lot of this boilerplate
up so we end up
with our three lines
of code to do three
fairly straightforward things.
And there's actually a box
talk about espresso out
in the developer sandbox
starting at 2:00-- so,
shortly after this talk ends.
So if you're
interested in Espresso,
you can go check that out.
But we want to use Espresso
to test the pie app.
And separate from
testing accessibility,
we've got a test that we'll see.
I push the one button to make
sure that the one appears over
in the digits area.
And so we write that test.
The test passes.
But there's one
more thing I can do.
So starting at Espresso 2.2, we
can add one more line of code
to enable these
accessibility checks.
And then my test
doesn't pass anymore.
And I get a whole
bunch of failures,
and actually it will
go through the whole UI
and give me essentially
the same list
that Casey just gave me with
his accessibility checker tool.
But here we're
finding these bugs
as a side effect of testing
that we may have already
been doing anyway.
So if you're using
Espresso already,
you can add one line
of code to your classes
and you get the accessibility
checking that's added now.
And then as we release new
features in this test library,
as we think of new ways
to automate this testing,
you'll continue to get
additional coverage
for accessibility.
So that's Espresso.
We'll talk a little
bit about Robolectric.
And I always struggle
a little bit more
to explain exactly
how Robolectric works.
I found out about it when I was
testing accessibility services.
I needed to inject mocks of
an Android framework class
into this class
that I had written.
And it turns out that's simply
not possible with Android.
But Robolectric allows
you to break these rules.
You can run Android dependent
classes on a standard Java
virtual machine.
And you can pretty much
make Android classes
behave any way you
need them to in order
to make your test work.
So they have the dream
of electric sheep.
I might have used bending spoon
because there is no final.
So I take that Espresso test and
I rewrite it for Robolectric.
Again, I get the test to pass,
but I have one line of code.
It's actually an
annotation in Java.
And now I get accessibility
checking as well.
I can also just do this with an
environment variable instead.
So when I click on the
one button in Robolectric,
it tells me it's missing
a content description.
And you'll notice
I'm not actually
getting the full
list of bugs that I
was able to catch with
Espresso, and that's
mostly because in addition
to there being no final,
there's no fully
inflated user interface.
So it can really
only check the things
that we're actively
clicking on in Robolectric.
So that's a couple ways
to do automated testing
for accessibility.
But you notice we
didn't actually
catch another fairly
significant flaw that we had
in the inaccessible experience.
We couldn't catch the fact
that when Hugh made a mistake,
it provided only
visual feedback.
And that's the
kind of thing where
you need a human in the loop.
You need it understand
is this what makes sense.
And so manual testing
remains the gold standard
for figuring out
if an experience is
going to make sense for
the full range of users.
But if you're using
automated tools
to catch the easy stuff--
the missing content
descriptions, decoy
clickable views,
views that are just too small to
be able to touch easily-- then
you can reserve the
brain power you've
got for the people
testing things to give you
valuable high level feedback.
And that's where I
started with this.
You get to this
high level feedback,
and the distinctions between
testing for accessibility
and testing for mainstream
use start to blur.
OK, how we're going
to fix this bug,
and that critical thinking
can lead you to breakthroughs
like auto complete.
But I think you'll get a lot
more of these extra benefits
of doing accessibility if
you're following these best
practices in your
day to day work,
not just finding them at the
end through manual testing.
So I invite you to integrate
these testing tools
into your software
development process.
And we'll keep
working on these tools
to enhance your apps
accessibility and help
the billion people with
a disability access
all the great products
that you're creating.
So with that, I'll
hand this back to Eve.
EVE ANDERSON: Thank you, Phil.
The National
Federation of the Blind
is an Important
partner for Google.
We've been working together
over the past few years
to improve the accessibility
of Google's products.
We've learned a lot from
the National Federation
of the Blind from their
insights and their advice
and from the
connections we've been
able to form with real users.
I'd like now to introduce
Mark Riccobono, President
of the National
Federation of the Blind,
to share some of his
insights with you.
Mark.
MARK RICCOBONO: Thank
you very much, Eve.
I appreciate the
opportunity to underscore
some things that
have already been
said from a user's perspective.
The National
Federation of the Blind
knows that blindness is
not the characteristic that
defines you or your future.
Every day, we raise
expectations of the blind,
because we recognize that low
expectations create obstacles
between blind people
and our dreams.
We know that blindness
doesn't hold you back,
but when technology
is not designed
with the blind in
mind, it creates
obstacles that prevents us
from achieving our dreams.
Now, we know from our
experience that when
you start with the prospect
that little is possible,
it's impossible to get more
than little accomplished.
So we want to start by
raising expectations.
And as users, that's
what we like to do.
A good example is in
the National Federation
of the Blind.
About four years
ago, we endeavored
to create a team
of engineers that
could build a car that a
blind person could drive.
I'm going to come
back to that, but let
me share a few other thoughts.
When accessibility is
built for all users,
it has a number of great
benefits when it's baked in.
And those have already
been shared to some extent.
What we find is that we get
innovations in user design
and feature priorities.
We develop highly effective
usability for all users.
We can come across
dramatically creative solutions
to sometimes
unexpected problems,
and we recognize cost
savings because we don't have
to go back and retrofit things.
As has also already
been pointed out,
often times innovations for
people with disabilities
become innovations
in the mainstream.
Some examples from
the history of dealing
with blind people, original
versions of the typewriter
were invented to help
blind people write,
long play records, which
allowed more information to be
delivered in audio format
to the blind, and of course
desktop scanning, which
is now so prevalent
but originally served
to use optical character
recognition to provide access
to information to blind people.
I'm here today to ask you if
you will rise to the challenge.
First of all, to
build all of your apps
to be accessible to as
many people as possible.
And then to use and
apply your talents
to create innovations for
people with disabilities.
Some examples you could
use for blind people
include enhanced
indoor navigation--
would have been helpful
here at this conference.
Automated image descriptions
and automatic creation
of tactile images that we can
create using 3D technology.
Or if you want to
think big, couldn't we
invent non-visual interfaces
to give blind people
access to information that would
allow us to fly an airplane?
I invite you to join
Google and the National
Federation of the Blind
and our dynamic team
to rise to the challenge,
to innovate without limits.
Because together, we can
transform dreams into reality
when users are involved.
And here's just one example from
my historic drive at Daytona
four years ago.
EVE ANDERSON: Thank you, Mark,
for your inspiring words.
I hope that each of you
will rise to the challenges
that Mark presented.
Speaking of challenges, in case
you missed the announcement
earlier this week, google.org
is committing $20 million
in grant funding for the first
of its kind Google Impact
Challenge Disabilities.
Through the challenge,
we'll identify and support
nonprofit organizations
working to increase access
to opportunity for
people with disabilities.
We're looking for big
ideas from nonprofits
that have technology at their
core and the ability to scale,
to impact people around the
world with disabilities.
I'd like to all of you
to learn more about
Google's accessibility efforts
and what you can do to make
your own app more
accessible by visiting
google.com/accessibility.
Try out your own
apps using Android's
built-in accessibility services.
Please visit us.
We're here for the
rest of the day.
We'll be in the
accessibility lab
in the google.org
sandbox on this floor.
And now, I'd like to
open it up for questions.
Thank you.
There's a microphone
in the middle.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question
about TalkBack.
So sometimes TalkBack
read things out in a way
that I wasn't expecting,
that's different.
And so I'm wondering if
you have documentation
on the versioning of TalkBack
similar to the documentation as
far as versioning for the
different Android operating
systems where someone could
go and read and understand
why it's behaving differently
than was expected?
CASEY BURKHARDT: Sure.
So there are definitely
some differences
to TalkBack across the
different Android versions,
and to some degree, we do have
these documented on our Android
support website at
support.google.com.
We probably still
could make improvements
to make some of these
differences between Android
versions a little more clear.
So thank you for that feedback.
I will definitely take
that back to the team.
AUDIENCE: Those testing
tools look cool.
I was wondering if
any of the feedback
about accessibility issues
could be pushed into earlier
in the build change.
So earlier in the
build time, you
can catch some of those
things and not even have
to get to the testing process?
PHIL WEAVER: So that's
already included
to some degree in Android Lint.
And we could look and
see what else we can do.
Android Lint will currently
check content descriptions
for you.
For example, if
you're missing one,
then you'll get a Lint error.
One thing is if you've got a
very complex app where you're
going to start dynamically
changing content descriptions,
often the solution to that is
you explicitly set the content
description to null in the file,
which tells the Linter I've got
this, don't bother me about it.
But then you don't really
have another way to check.
And so this is a way to
check it at run time.
So yeah, I appreciate
the feedback.
We certainly want to try
and provide the feedback
at different levels so we have
more than one crack at catching
these things.
AUDIENCE: Two things.
One, I know 100 digits of pi.
So if you need user
testers, I'm your guy.
Second thing, how would
switch access work
with an infinite scroll feed
like Facebook, for instance?
Would it just go forever down?
PHIL WEAVER: Well, at least
to handle scroll events,
you can scroll forward and
backward if you select a view
that can be scrolled.
And since Facebook, I believe,
does actually scroll forever,
I think you can scroll forever.
But it'll scroll
one view at a time.
So if the user wants to keep
scrolling, they can go for it.
If they want to select
something that's
shown on the screen
at some point on it,
It'll probably just do that.
AUDIENCE: Is Google
doing anything
with EEG headset as an
input method for users
with severe physical
disabilities?
EVE ANDERSON: That's a
very interesting question,
and I think that is an area
that's ripe for research.
I think there are
improvements being
made in techniques for
capturing signals like that.
We don't have anything to
announce in that area, however.
AUDIENCE: So I think you said
the Espresso stuff is available
now.
The accessibility checker
in the app that you showed,
is that available yet?
CASEY BURKHARDT:
So we just wanted
to give an early demo
of accessibility checker
here today at IO.
Unfortunately, we
don't have anything
to announce regarding
availability.
But please stay tuned following
us on Twitter at Google Access.
We're going to be
sharing more information
on Twitter regarding
availability and logistics.
EVE ANDERSON: And we have
time for one last question.
AUDIENCE: So I've been
doing a lot of work
with the Blind
Institute of Technology.
And their Android users wanted
me to ask about two features--
screen blinking via tap
gestures and turning TalkBack
on and off.
I know you can pause it,
but actually turning it
off and on via
gestures as well, are
those any features that
are planned in the future?
EVE ANDERSON: Do you
want to take it, Casey?
CASEY BURKHARDT: Sure.
So there is some
work done already
to improve how easy it
is to enable and disable
TalkBack on the fly.
In TalkBack 4.2.0, you can
actually long press both volume
keys at the same time
for about a second or two
and that will toggle TalkBack
on or off on that device.
And that works in
both directions.
So if TalkBack is running,
I can long press those keys,
disable it, and the same gesture
on those keys to re-enable it.
Regarding screen blinking,
that's definitely a feature
we've heard a lot
of requests for.
So we'll definitely make
sure to take that back
to the TalkBack team.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
EVE ANDERSON: So I
have to apologize.
That was the last
question we had time
for during this session.
However, we will be around
for the rest of the day
in the accessibility section
of the google.org sandbox.
So please come chat with us,
see live demos of everything,
and give us your
suggestions and feedback.
Thank you so much, everyone.